Hello everyone. Today I would like to
introduce an efficient non-linear
manifold reduced order model. My name is
Youngsoo and this work is done with
Yangyu, David, and Tarek.
Why reduced order model? What are
surrogate models? You are looking at a
beautiful simulation model by smooth
particle hydrodynamics for shape charge
penetration. This simulation is well
matched with the experiment data, but
very expensive. One full simulation
takes 7.4 days. This is unfortunate in
multi-query applications such as design
optimization. Therefore, many have tried
to build an efficient surrogate models
that accelerates their simulations
without losing much accuracy.
Such a surrogate model can be built by
first considering a parameter space D
where you collect data by solving full
order model for several sample points.
Then you apply machine learning
techniques to build a surrogate model.
Various techniques are available as
listed here. Then using the surrogate
model, you can accelerate simulations
with various query points here and there
and many more.
These surrogate models can be
categorized
by its level of intrusiveness. For
example, from black box approach denoted
as BB, which is the least intrusive
method, to the linear subspace reduced
order model and non-linear manifold
reduced order model, which are fully
intrusive.
Roughly speaking, more intrusiveness
means more accuracy. So ROMs are more
accurate than the black box approach. On
the other hand, more intrusiveness mean
means less speed up. So the BB method is
faster than ROMs in general. We are
surrogate model that is NM ROM.
Unfortunately,
the NM ROM is currently slower than the
full order model, which is not
practical. However, we have improved the
NM ROM speed up tremendously. This is
our main contribution. To explain what
NM ROM is, I will compare NM ROM with LS
ROM step by step. First of all, LS ROM
uses linear subspace solution
representation, while NM ROM uses a
non-linear manifold representation using
non-linear map G. We use autoencoder to
obtain the non-linear map. Then both LS
ROM and NM ROM substitutes these
solution representations into the
governing equations. Since these are
overdetermined systems, we close them by
minimizing the norm of the residuals. By
the way, we have problems here. You see
these non-linear terms still scale with
the full order model size. This makes
the whole procedure more expensive than
the corresponding full order models,
which is completely useless. To resolve
these serious problems, we developed a
hyper reduction techniques.
In hyper reduction, we try to reduce the
cost of the following three non-linear
terms shown in red. Our hyper reduction
techniques first select a subset of
non-linear terms to avoid the evaluation
of the full size.
We do that by following gappy POD
procedure. This implies that only subset
of the neural network outputs need to be
computed as illustrated with the orange
discs in this decoder. Note that the
shallower network involves the less
number of hidden nodes for the
computation of the selected outputs.
Furthermore, we build a sparser network
by applying a mask to further increase
the efficiency.
Here we compare the performance of
various surrogate models in an advection
dominated 2D viscous Burgers' equation,
which is known to be a hard problem for
ROMs to achieve a good accuracy.
As you can see from the movies, NM ROM
and FOM are almost identical in eyeball
norms, while LS ROM shows fictitious
oscillations in front of the shock wave.
The BB approach looks okay in eyeball
norm. However, quantitatively, the BB
approach has the worst maximum relative
error, that is around 38%.
On the other hand, NM ROM achieves less
than 1% maximum relative error.
Furthermore, a considerable speed up is
achieved by the NM ROM.
In summary, an efficient non-linear
manifold ROM is introduced where
solution dimension is reduced by
non-linear manifold solution
representation.
The non-linear dimension is reduced by
hyper reduction.
This NM ROM is supposed to achieve a
higher speed up for large scale
problems, so we will definitely apply it
to large scale problems. Furthermore, we
will tackle instability problems such as
Rayleigh-Taylor instability. For more
details about our NM ROM, please check
out our paper and do not hesitate
reaching out to us. Thank you so much
for listening.